the former US National Security adviser
and Secretary of State Henry Kissinger
has died at the age of 100 under
President Richard Nixon Kissinger was a
key figure in opening up diplomatic ties
with communist China back in the
1970s but he's also been accused of war
crimes for supporting repressive
dictatorships especially in Latin
America as well as bombing campaigns in
Southeast Asia Mike Hanah looks back on
his
life at the age of 100 Henry Kissinger
was still Globe trotting meeting the
Chinese president in Beijing you've just
celebrated your 100th birthday and I
wish you a long and healthy life it is a
great
privilege to be able to visit China
significantly he was also granted a
meeting with the defense minister a man
sanctioned by the US who had refused any
form of communication with Biden
Administration officials including his
opposite number in the Pentagon it was
52 years since Kissinger had first held
secret meetings with Chinese leaders
when he was the US National Security
adviser and then I know all of you will
want to hear from the new secretary of
state there is no country in the world
where it is conceivable that a man of my
Origins could be standing here next to
the president of the United States
Kissinger was born in Germany in
1923 he and his family fled the Nazis in
1938 eventually settling in the US he
joined the army during World War II
using his language skills in Military
Intelligence after the war Kissinger
earned a doctorate in political science
at Harvard his ambition to shape US
foreign policy Kissinger got his chance
when he joined the Nixon White House in
1969 where his job was to help end the
war in Vietnam he oversaw the secret
carpet bombing campaign in Cambodia it's
estimated as many as a million people
were killed opponents of the war say
Kissinger should have been tried for war
crimes he never apologized I'm
certainly was strongly supportive of it
it was
correct and it was in the American
interest on Christmas Day 1972 the US
launched an air war on North Vietnam to
convince Hanoi to resume peace talks the
president within 10 days you got these
guys to the table which no other method
could have done this led to the 1973
Paris Peace Accords and a Nobel Peace
Prize for Kissinger but the war didn't
end until
1975 the Nixon Administration saw
Vietnam as key to stopping the spread of
Communism but when it came to the Soviet
Union and China Kissinger persuaded
Nixon to try deant in other words a
slight defrosting of the Cold War the
result Washington and Moscow negotiated
their first Arms Control
treaties and Nixon visited China in
1972 for Kissinger this was all about
giving the US a tactical Advantage our
strategy was to position ourselves in
such a way that we were closer to Soviet
Union and China than they were to each
other ah so that in every
crisis we had more options than they did
meanwhile Kissinger was still fighting
the Cold War in South America and Europe
backing military governments in Chile
Greece and
Argentina he denied supporting the coup
which deposed Chilean president Salvador
elend in
1973 leading to the dictatorship of
General austo Pinos there was no
policy uh since to Assassin into
assassinate any foreign official secret
White House recordings later revealed
that Kissinger knew the CIA helped pin
launched the coup and that he had
canceled the state Department's warnings
to pin's government against killing
political opponents his
defense sometimes Statesmen have to
choose among evils Kissinger invented
the use of shuttle diplomacy to help
broker an end to the 1973 war between
Israel and Egypt creating the foundation
for the 1978 Camp David Accords after
Nixon resigned in 1974 Kissinger
continued as Secretary of State under
President Gerald Ford and spent the
remaining Decades of his life as an
informal adviser to world leaders and
corporations to his critics a warmonger
to his admirers a consumate diplomat but
recognized by all as a man who changed
the course of
history
let speak now to Steve Clemens he's the
host of alzer's weekly show the bottom
line and is the founding editor at large
at seore which is a new digital media
platform he joins us now live from
Washington DC thank you for your time so
Henry Kissinger was both celebrated and
controversial can you put his legacy in
shaping Foreign Affairs into
perspective yeah well I mean I think
there was no more influential foreign
policy intellectual and and and
participant than Henry Kissinger he
shaped the entire modern era not just
since the end of the Cold War but before
the Cold War his book on nuclear weapons
and foreign policy in the 1950s became
the seminal document at that time on how
to think about nuclear weapons this is
before the opening to China uh before
daytont with Russia and before many of
his misdeeds he is he is reviled uh
around the world by many for for having
no filter for human rights and embracing
autocrats and thugs but he is celebrated
by those who see that he diffused major
tensions in the world particularly with
Russia at a key moment uh but also China
and led uh to a very different path at
that time and I think many people today
who look at the complexities in the
world there are a lot of Human Rights
atrocities in the world but they're
asking where is the realist today who
can help negotiate and channel uh
between powers in the world that are
emerging and I think what's interesting
is that Kissinger as consequential as he
as controversial as he was never stopped
being consequential even in April when
going to China meeting Xi Jinping when
America and China were clearly on a
Divergent path and perhaps on a train W
uh course he stepped in and basically
set a floor on that relationship
reminding both sides how fundamentally
globally consequential that relationship
was so he was not loved and I knew Henry
Kissinger I was the first first director
of the Nixon Center in Washington uh in
the in the early 1990s and Henry was my
co-chairman of my board uh so I had a
lot of interaction with him and he was a
man who knew he had a place in history
who was worried how that was going to be
but he continued he was worried how it
would be shaped and who would attack him
but yet he didn't at another level care
that much and Steve he was of course a
holocaust Survivor born in Germany and
then later moved as a young child to
America how do you think that shaped his
life and choices
well I think it it made him realize how
fragile life and status and title was he
was uh he felt that his father was
humiliated came to this country with
nothing and if anything and I you when I
talked to Dr Kissinger I think it became
clear that he became an overachieving
person someone who took everything he
did um incredibly seriously he outran
his comp
competition and and he was someone who
always made whatever role or job he had
something
consequential Steve good to get your
personal perspective Steve Clemens the
host of alzer's weekly show the bottom
line